Gather round for the week fourteen playoff picture.
How do you all like your sweaters?
I love it!
Get out of my way Mahomes!
HEY, IF Y'ALL CAN JUST BEHAVE, I'LL BUY Y'ALL CHEESE FRENCH FRIES AT THE FUDGE FOOD COURT!
Thanks dad!
Okay, I can do this. I think you all will fit.
From my vantage point Witt, they clearly won't!
Uh Aaron, it doesn't look like you're in.
If I could just get a little help. Okay, well if we beat the Falcons and the Bears and the Jets
And of course you need the Seahawks and the Vikings to lose out and the Bears just stop playing football.
Wait, where's the NFC East?
C'mon, c'mon!  Taking you down with me!
Hey Dak, here's our opening.
We beat the Bears, we have a chance!
Sorry everybody, I think the Cowboys are in.
You stole my sweater!
Run Lamar, run!
Whatcha doin' little guy?
I'm trying to make a playoff push!
Awwww!
Come on, Witt, take control.
Okay! So
I disagree Jason!
I didn't say anything.
I can tell you Kirk's out!
I DON'T LIKE THAT!
Russell's in!
Wait, where did he come from?
Bucs out!
Great job everybody else!
Say Brees!
Brees!
MAHOMES!
WOW! WHAT A FUN, EASY
picture
Yeah, I guess if the rest of the NFC loses we might make it in so I don't know.
Probably have no chance, but at least you might as well subscribe and like this channel. It's all I got.